Super Bowl is the number one ad I
believe in in the world television
commercial and it's not even that I
don't think people watch commercials
people watch commercials it's the cost
associated with making a commercial in
return for how much is consumed and do
people buy [__] but all these
commercials being made for what people
watch the content not the thing that
interrupts you from the content not just
the way the world Works which is why ads
have to be
either you have to make sure people want
to watch
there's not a single creative agency
that of the like the great 30 40 which I
have incredible admiration for what they
do in making a television commercial the
problem is if they ever took those
talents and refurbished them to
understand how to make day in and day
out creative work in Social
the talents that all these creative
agencies would have a much better life
they would enjoy it could you imagine
being someone who's creative sitting in
nine months of meetings and then a year
later like seven months later seeing a
television commercial and seeing a speck
of what you thought in it 16 months to
get to get to something that doesn't see
the light of day and ends up on The
Cutting Room floor you know they didn't
grow up the way these guys think about
creativity they think that's normal I'm
watching like creatives come from like
really great places and work for us and
have like that Epiphany 18 months in it
takes literally like a year and a half
just to like to reframe it and then in
reverse the amount of creatives that
have left Bain or the last two years
that were homegrown that worked there
for six seven eight years and decided
they needed to scratch the edge of going
and working try something else that's
something else top the insanity of like
it's really interesting to talking to
them because I talked to them this is
how I get my insights yeah when they
leave they like that they're put on an
ego pedestal at Baker if you're a very
senior creative there's a humility it's
the same way I work it's the way because
everything takes on the face when
Dustin's in the lounges are saying hey
can I tell you the truth on my feedback
here it's like laughable to me that
we've spent this much time and he still
has to hedge him saying I don't like
that content from you in a world where
I'm completely detached for my own
content yeah and you want the future you
want to know the insights I also see the
results it's not like he's so profound
it's not working yeah like it's not me
or him the question was only posed to
him because it's not working it's a
commitment to giving a [__] about the
audience not me or Dustin so they like
going to a place where they're being put
on a pedestal they love being fancy they
say to me directly people that have been
growing up Vayner yeah they're like we
like it I like the prestige I like that
I walk around and everyone kissed the
ground that I work on but real talk it
feels super weird to like not do
anything like just they're not operating
in the field they're not like close no
it's just like it takes me a full year
to do one thing like I've come from a
place where we make like and I get to
see my and and that corrodes at the
person's creativity
goals to
cry they don't hear that ever in the
region ever Gary ever they don't hear it
in America every region nobody's made
that commitment yet except for small
businesses and creators entrepreneurs
small businesses but the Fortune 500
landscape is only hearing that for the
first time by us and it's working I
don't say that everyone's going to look
like us out of anything other than it's
working for us and people copy what
works
you know what I mean like that's just
going to be the case as we continue to
win market share
people are going to adjust that's what
everyone does that's what business does
you adjust reality
is listening to what the consumer wants
and then doing that right but and I do
respect the Counterpoint to that which
is like
the Henry Ford thing or the court or the
Porsche thing I don't know who exactly
said it but you know if I listen to My
Consumer I would have made a faster
horse I do believe in that
I you know however to me it's not doing
what the customer wants it's making what
you want what are the customers paying
attention
to me this isn't like what do you want I
don't make anything based on I take the
feedback it affects my creative process
all the comments but it's not about like
what do you want like what they want for
me is garage sale video so I can just
make that all day long it's not that
it's
not having ego
and staying curious
like
I don't know how these agency creatives
continue to think that they're their
worth is wrapped up in making a
television commercial in 2023.
this by the way the Super Bowl is the
number one ad I believe in in the world
it's a television commercial there is
anomalies there's tiny enigmas there's
little weird blips but 365 days a year
eight billion people yeah and it's not
even that I don't think people watch
commercials people watch commercials
it's the cost
associated with making a commercial in
return for how much is consumed and
do people buy [__] yeah because
I don't care about the prestige that's
good for the actor that's in it
was that did that make you buy Coca-Cola
okay well the [__] are we doing here
this is marketing to make [__] happen
I don't do content for any other reason
to impact people positively or create
something that I want to happen in
business
the end there's only two things one's
very selfish one's very selfless and I'm
incredibly comfortable in that
environment like why I would never make
content if I didn't think all the people
that stopped me and say thank you or
they buy empathy wines like it's got to
be one of the two but all these
commercials being made for what you know
how many agencies make commercials
completely based on they want to meet
the actor that's going to be in the
commercial they literally pitch like
Michael B Jordan Michael B Jordan is
pitched at every commercial because
every human wants to meet that
[__] because he's the awesome
I'm obsessed with him yeah he's the best
but like that I'm not gonna pitch
Michael B Jordan to this coffee brand
because I want to meet Michael B Jordan
I'm gonna do something that's actually
gonna sell this [__] coffee yeah
I know
I watch it every day
the industry's incredibly vulnerable
it's gonna be such a major change the
next 30 Years
it doesn't even exist what they like
like connected TV is going to eat up all
commercials it's all based on social
media and proxies
the way you plan we're doing a very
substantial thing called modern comms
planning it's similar to our sock and
pack on the media side I don't talk
about the media part a lot because for
most of my audience they don't have a
million dollars to spend on Advertising
so it's not relevant but
I'm going to more because I'm going to
stand up this principle
which is which is the way every brand
buys media is based on reach and
frequency
yeah how many people will this reach how
often will it be mix all the sense in
the world if I reach you
that have always been Legacy industry
the problem is all the reporting is fake
what do you mean
it means it's just not true like when
websites say well this is how many
people it reached it didn't it's not
actually being consumed don't tell me
how many people went to your website
tell me how many people consume the ad
or watch the video to the end like I
said earlier the Oscars were up 18 and a
half percent I'm like cool and
because what you're alluding to my team
is that the ads did better and I'm
telling you they did worse
the less people watch the ads this year
in the last year you know or what makes
you say that common sense
and what did they say when you said this
year than last year
one more 70 year old now looks at their
phone during commercials and one more 15
year old entered the pool of watching
the Oscars that never even thought about
consuming
people watch the content not the thing
that interrupts you from the content
not just the way the world works
which is why ads have to be the content
you have to make sure people want to
watch